listen here's the thing I don't know who
is lying is not pulling a name out of a
hat today we are playing two truths and
a lie
we're going to be meeting three people
and hearing them tell truths and lie to
us too many people are gonna be telling
the truth
one of them is gonna be lying who it is
we don't know
[Music]
welcome welcome strangers hi this is
terrifying I competed with a WWE Hall of
Famer and a professional wrestling match
I was once the bodyguard for Sam Smith
for an event I took a shot with John
Elway on a boat I have questions for
Shane yes okay have you ever done any
work with any other wrestling promotions
besides the beat when I was a wrestler I
wrestled independently so there's like
the WWE and there's independent
professional wrestling so I never
competed in the WWE but I wrestled
independently well from Ocean well this
promotion in particular was called
Southern Championship Wrestling so I
only wrestled in the southeast
what was your wrestling name my
wrestling character was a I looked very
different at the time but I played a
surfer by the name of rip malibu what
year was this this was 2006 and what
city DeBary Florida so you wrestled with
the W wrestler somebody who's under
contract with that
whee-hee-hee you trying to find the
legal loophole it's gone
no no so he became a hall-of-famer ten
years after this but he was a he was a
big wrestler in the 70s and 80s what's
his name and Larry's abisco okay
wrestle him in 2006 and then he went in
the Hall of Fame
I believe in 2016 is that his name that
he wrestles under okay and this was a
one time wrestling match and who won
oh he way he did yeah he's a
hall-of-famer wanted to give you the
benefit of the doubt how did he beat you
at Lois's
I move I remember correctly in wrestling
there's a thing called a schoolboy and
it's just a simple like pinning maneuver
how did this match come about well I had
been wrestling independently for a
couple years this company they set up
this match with
you know I was an up-and-coming
independent wrestler at the time and he
was I think he's like in his sixties at
the time but he was like she was kind of
on his retirement circuit so yeah it was
kind of the up-and-coming wrestler versa
you wrestle you wrestle someone in their
60s yeah yeah I was 19 and I wrestled a
dude in his sixties okay Sam Smith
bodyguard yes have you been a bodyguard
for others no I used to work at Madame
Tussauds in San Francisco that's where
I'm originally from
obviously they do figures of celebrities
every now and then they'll reach out to
celebrities they'll come in and surprise
guests or you know customers coming in
by being the wax figure right so we were
doing a reveal and I was a part of the
marketing team we were a very small team
and I don't know what possessed them to
think yes the smallest youngest person
on our marketing team should be the one
to be Sam Smith's bodyguard while we're
hiding him away before the event
why didn't Sam Smith come with his own
security he had one security guard a
makeup artist and like a handler so he
had some people with him but we were
also trying to conceal that there was a
celebrity here were you given any sort
of training before this no I graduated
college so you didn't have like a weapon
no I didn't have a uniform or anything I
was just like in business attire was Sam
Smith nice yeah really nice he did take
a photo with me did he post it to
Facebook instrument approximately how
many likes did it get on Instagram um I
don't really count but it was like a
hundred which is all my friends john
elway yes what year was this not that
long ago maybe 2014 I think about yeah
it was in quarterly in Idaho he has a
cabin on that Lake and so does my family
and so we were out on the water for the
day and then we went to get gas at
Rockford Bay John Elway has this like
super notorious boat that's like got a
green chili pepper on it and it's like
this long cigarette boat that everyone
on the bay knows and he came up to get
gas and attached to that gas station is
this bar called shooter
we went and had some drinks and then
came back down and we were coming back
down John le was pulling up to get gas
my uncle yelled out to John he said like
it was like a Seahawks thing because the
Seahawks Broncos Super Bowl had like
that was the year before that John like
laughed and then he said like hey take a
shot with us and as we were like leaving
away we passed them a cup and he took a
shot in his boat and we kept going first
of all so who was operating this but
also the people doing the shots so are
you saying that John Elway was drinking
and boating yes well I mean it's pretty
common I think but I feel like I'm in
hell but I'm not sure if it's yeah I
don't think it's legal I'm not sure the
legality but I will say that it is kind
of common I think to have like a drink
and boat but there was a lot of us I
mean it was like me my uncle my mom my
grandfather it was just him and his wife
so maybe he passed over duties to her
and it was a shot of tequila yes where
I'm not fancy so it's just like the well
from shooters I'm curious as to how you
actually interacted with in the first
place why you I'm like no one else just
cuz no it wasn't just me like my uncle
also he yelled out at him initially yeah
I think maybe just because we were had
already had a few drinks we felt
inclined to do so me my mom my uncle and
my grandfather did you guys recognize
him instantly
yeah it's like he's got one of those
cabins that everyone like if you do like
a tour of the lake in your boat or
whatever people like drive by and do
likes and that's where John always cabin
is and it's boat like I said is this
super long cigarette boat that has like
this green chilly on the side it says
like el something where was it coeur
d'alene idaho Lake Coeur d'Alene
my gut feeling is wrestling is a lie
yeah my feeling is shot is the line my
gut feeling is shot is alai - okay but
so we agree that Sam Smith is real I
think I think shots a lot I think shot
is a borrowed story I think that
happened to someone else
truly kids because I've just been his
uncle yes I related to him yeah I felt
like there was slightly less certainty I
do feel like Sam Smith is real I feel
like that's a situation that some
company would throw their way into to me
like Kelly I'm security here you go
where do you Entertainment it's just
kind of thing that happens I'm like 70%
sure Wrestling Israel why do you feel
like wrestling Israel it's a weird thing
to make of your husband watches rescue
daddy my husband watches my husband's a
huge wrestling enthusiast and so he
watches like a lot of wrestling with a
lot of independent wrestling living
shots is alive I think that shows i mr.
Devon here I'm gonna stray from the
group I think that wrestling is the line
so I did Brussels larry's abisco the w/e
hall-of-famer I was the bodyguard for
Samsonite
I did take a shot with John Elway so I
think I got this wrong no I'm just
kidding it's also not even a borrowed
story I just made it up Wow my god
honestly it was just the drinking and
boating they threw me everything else I
was like that's like the most real part
of the story
[Laughter]